[Applause]
what's up org nation welcome to a very
special bonus video just for you to talk
about the last shed I now by this point
in time reviews are up most of the press
s screen the movie I was beyond lucky
and I'm so grateful to have attended the
premiere as a representative and
ambassador for poor nation but I want to
be clear as a Star Wars fan and as a fan
of Star Wars fans I am NOT going to be
discussing any specific plot points or
spoilers in this video today the point
of this video is just to give you my
initial thoughts and reaction while
staying as vague as humanly possible now
it goes against my job as a content
creator to tell you to log off the
internet and just go in fresh but I do
encourage everyone just to shut it down
for a few days go into the last Jedi
with zero expectations and a blank slate
but if you're looking for a little hype
or a little reassurance prepare for the
jump to Lightspeed and we'll get into it
right now if you've read any of the
social media reactions after the
screenings you probably noticed a lot of
people saying that they need to see the
movie again and that's exactly how I
feel it's been three days since I've
seen the last Jedi and the only word
replaying in my head over and over and
over again is bold this is unlike any
Star Wars movie out there and it's bound
to be the most divisive Star Wars movie
that exists are you into it that's up to
you to decide but oh my god the
conversations you're gonna be at any bar
restaurant party for the next six months
and undoubtedly hear people discussing
the last Jedi in depth in some corner of
the room we knew Rian Johnson was gonna
shake up the franchise in some kind of
crazy way and you can sit around and
speculate what that can mean or how he
could get into that and then you can
just throw that all into the trash
because every single major plot point I
mean you could guess the whole thing but
not be able to guess how he gets there
it's unbelievable this is not your
simple Star Wars movie it's unbelievably
complex and groundbreaking and whether
you love it or hate it
you're gonna be talking about it for
weeks months years to come
those who criticize the force awakens
for being like a soft reboot of a new
hope or canopy Oh
very happy with this one and if you're
wondering if the last Jedi is a
reimagining of the Empire Strikes Back
ha lmao no that's really all I want to
say for now for the risk of keeping it
vague but I wanted to give you guys my
initial thoughts and feelings on the
movie if you're looking for a full
written review you can head to ET
online.com where the hunch my Chewbacca
John Boone has written a delightful
piece on the film I will be diving into
some in-depth topics and spoilers and
discussions after audiences have had the
chance to see the movie on December 15th
and any video that I post will have a
very obvious spoiler warning splashed
all over the place thank you guys so
much for watching make sure you give
this video a thumbs up if you enjoyed
and let me know your spoiler-free
thoughts on the last guy please
please in the comments keep it spoiler
free don't spoil it for anyone else and
you can always tweet me at Ashe Cross
and may the force be with you